[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Heinz
Wolf und Marietta Slomka guten Abend wir
werden uns in Karlsruhe sehen war dann
wohl der Satz des Tages ausgesprochen
von CSU und Linke in seltener Einigkeit
beide Parteien würden durch die
Wahlrechtsreform am meisten Federn
lassen die Linke vermutlich nicht mal
mehr im Bundestag sitzen denn künftig
soll gelten wenn eine Partei bundesweit
die 5% Hürde reist kommt keiner von ihr
rein auch nicht mit gewonnenen
Wahlkreisen das könnte auch für die
csu-problematisch werden zumindest
könnte sie nicht mehr so viele
Überhangmandate aus Bayern geltend
machen kein Wunder dass beide Parteien
schäumen die CDU schäumt mit ihrer
Schwester natürlich solidarisch mit die
Stimmung im Bundestag heute giftig
das Hohe Haus ist brechend voll der
Blutdruck vieler Parlamentarier
wahrscheinlich hoch lang und
leidenschaftlich streitet der Bundestag
über seine eigene Größe und über das
ampelgesetz zur Verkleinerung
wir sind in der Lage eine Reform an uns
selbst vorzunehmen wir werden über 100
Abgeordneten weniger meine Damen und
Herren und das ist eine
Wahnsinnsleistung sie schaffen ein
anderes Wahlrecht sie
endpersonalisieren ist und sorgen damit
dafür dass es nicht nur
verfassungsrechtlich prekär wird sondern
es schadet der Demokratie
Kern der Reform Überhang und
Ausgleichsmandate werden abgeschafft
nach wie vor entscheidet die Zweitstimme
über das Kräfteverhältnis im Bundestag
neu ist wer mit der Erststimme einen
Wahlkreis gewinnt ist nicht mehr
automatisch drin sondern erst wenn das
auch durch das Partei Ergebnis der
Zweitstimme gedeckt ist
630 Abgeordnete mehr nicht
eigentlich geplant waren weniger als 600
die AFD kritisiert das als Aufweichung
wegen der eigennützigen Erhöhung der
Mandatszahl in letzter Sekunde und dem
fehlenden direktdemokratischen
Fortschritt werden wir die AFD dem
ampelentwurf nicht zu stimmen der größte
pulstreiber heute die sogenannte
grundmandatsklausel wird gestrichen
bisher galt wenn eine Partei drei
Wahlkreise gewinnt darf sie in
Fraktionsstärke ins Parlament ungeachtet
der 5% Hürde die Linke ist nur deshalb
drin und auch die CSU holte beim letzten
Mal zwar fast alle Wahlkreise aber nur
knapp mehr als 5% der Zweitstimmen in
einem Bundesland kann eine Partei alle
Wahlkreise gewinnen in Bayern wären das
beispielsweise 46 aber nach ihrem
Wahlrecht besteht die Möglichkeit dass
kein einziger Kandidat in den Deutschen
Bundestag einziehen und das nennen sie
fair und demokratisch CSU macht aus
jeder Diskussion über die Verkleinerung
des Deutschen Bundestages eine
Diskussion über die CSU aber ich will
ihnen eines sagen sie müssen damit
klarkommen dass es auf der Welt und in
diesem Land auch mal einen einzigen Tag
geht an denen es nicht um die CSU geht
sondern um dieses Land aber auch die
Linke fürchtet um ihre parlamentarische
Existenz in der Krise steckt sie ohnehin
ihre Herausforderung bei der nächsten
Bundestagswahl beginnt auch mit W ist
aber nicht das Wahlrecht sondern heißt
Wagenknecht ich wünsche Ihnen politisch
alles erdenklich gerechte wir werden uns
in Karlsruhe sehen in Karlsruhe sitzt
das Bundesverfassungsgericht vor das
Union und Linke jetzt ziehen wollen auf
der Tribüne verfolgen auch
wahlrechtsexperten die Debatte ihre
erste Einschätzung das Wahlrecht sei
jetzt stimmiger für Aspekte wie die
grundmandatsklausel aber müssten
zusätzlichen her
das Wahlrecht ist jetzt so transparent
glaube ich dass das Verfassungsgericht
sehr gut damit zurecht kommt und die
Klarheit der jetzigen Regelung führt
dazu dass solche Nachjustierung leicht
möglich sind wenn sie denn politisch
gewünscht werden Signale für
kompromissangebote gab es heute in der
Debatte wenn der Puls dann wieder unten
ist
eine der Meldungen dieses Tages ist dass
der Internationale Strafgerichtshof
heute Haftbefehl erlassen hat gegen
Wladimir Putin politisch ist das ein
Paukenschlag die Ukraine sammelt ja
praktisch schon seit Kriegsbeginn
Beweise für Verbrechen der russischen
Armee die Ankläger vom Strafgerichtshof
in Den Haag konzentrieren sich zunächst
aber nur auf einen Vorwurf die
Entführung ukrainischer Kinder es sollen
tausende sein die aus besetzten Gebieten
nach Russland verschleppt werden die
ZDF-Redaktion frontal hat solchen Fällen
nachgespürt Christiane Hoffmann
berichtet
es sind tausende ukrainische Kinder die
die Besatzungstruppen nach Russland
verschleppten Kinder wie die 15 von
Natalia Ludwig aus einem Heim in Hessen
eines Morgens sei ein Bus der Besatzer
gekommen erzählt sie
sie sagten wenn du nicht in 10 Minuten
gepackt hast gehen die Kinder ohne dich
wir nehmen sie dir weg ich hatte keine
Wahl
es war beängstigtend sagt ein Junge wir
wussten nicht wohin sie uns bringen dann
sagten sie es ginge in die Ferien
die Reise führt auf die besetzte
Halbinsel Krim zunächst in ein Haus mit
hunderten anderen Kindern über die Krim
wurden offenbar viele der Kinder danach
nach Russland gebracht und zur Adoption
freigegeben die russische Propaganda
präsentiert vermeintlich glückliche
Kinder mit ihren neuen Familien in den
Weiten Russlands Assimilation das Ziel
alles ukrainische sollen sie vergessen
als Kriegsverbrechen stuft der
Internationale Strafgerichtshof dieses
Vorgehen ein und hat Haftbefehl gegen
Präsident Putin erlassen
beim internationalen Recht ist des
Besatzungsmächten untersagt Zivilisten
aus dem Gebiet in dem sie leben in
andere Gebiete zu verlegen Kinder
genießen nach der Genfer Konvention
besonderen Schutz
ein zweiter Haftbefehl erging gegen die
russische kinderrechtsbeauftragte Maria
levor belowa sie hat diese
Verschleppungen organisiert und selbst
ein Kind aus mariopol adoptiert jetzt
hört sich Russland über den Haftbefehl
inakzeptabel sei schon die Formulierung
sagte Putins Sprecher piskow Russland
erkenne den Gerichtshof nicht an
deswegen seien alle Entscheidungen für
Russland nichtig von der Propaganda
inszenierte Adoptionen um die 14.000
Kinder sein so nach Russland verschleppt
worden schätzen die Ukraine sie haben
die Fälle recherchiert und im
Internationalen Strafgerichtshof
übergeben präsidente Lenski nennt die
Anklage historisch
Kinder von ihren Familien zu trennen in
jede Möglichkeit zu nehmen mit ihren
Verwandten in Kontakt zu treten Kinder
in Russland zu verstecken all das ist
offensichtlich russische Staatspolitik
Natalia Ludwig konnte nach Wochen ihre
15 Kinder mit gefälschten Dokumenten
nach Georgien bringen tausende andere
sollen ihre ukrainische Herkunft
vergessen
sarattacke beiß uns von unserer
Redaktion Recht und Justiz Sarah die
erste Frage die sich einem eigentlich
aufdrängt ist kann jetzt Putin
tatsächlich verhaftet werden theoretisch
ja sobald Putin ein Land wie Deutschland
betritt also eine Vertragspartei des
Internationalen Strafgerichtshofs wird
er festgenommen wird er ausgeliefert
davor schützt auch seine Immunität als
Staatsoberhaupt schützt ihn davon nicht
und es sind immerhin 123 Länder Mitglied
des Internationalen Strafgerichtshofs
allerdings Großmächte wie Russland
selber die USA wie China sind es nicht
das heißt wenn Putin in diesen Ländern
ist muss er nicht festgenommen werden er
kann es aber das heißt in Russland
solange in Russland bleibt ist er
erstmal sicher aber seine Reisefreiheit
ist doch deutlich eingeschränkt er muss
befürchten überall auch festgenommen zu
werden
schon gehört Russland reagierte ganz
empört hat aber gleichzeitig dann auch
gesagt und ja das interessiert uns
eigentlich gar nicht weil das hat für
uns rechtlich sowieso keine Konsequenzen
eben weil Russland nicht Vertragspartner
ist das stimmt deshalb muss Russland
selber und die russischen Behörden
höchsten Putin nicht festnehmen nicht
ausliefern aber und das macht diesen
hassbefehl so besonders und auch so
historisch es wird Putin persönlich
vorgeworfen verantwortlich zu sein für
die Entführung ukrainischer Kinder nach
Russland das heißt den Ermittlern ist es
gelungen Beweise zu finden die ein
Haftbefehl begründen beweisen die
belegen sollen das Putin selber
persönlich mit seinem Umfeld oder auch
in dem er Untergebenen nicht anders
kontrolliert hat verantwortlich ist für
die Entführung dieser Kinder und das in
amtierende Staatsoberhaupt so etwas
vorgeworfen wird ist wirklich einmalig
das gab es erst einmal 2009 dass der
Internationale Strafgerichtshof einen
Haftbefehl gegen einen amtierenden
Staatsoberhaupt erlassen hat das war
damals gegen den damaligen amtierenden
Präsidenten des Sudan den in der Regel
wenn Kriegsverbrechen überhaupt
nachgewiesen werden können und angeklagt
werden dann sind es die Soldaten selber
die vergewaltigen die zivil töten die
Kinder entführen die dann am Ende auch
angeklagt werden aber nicht das
Staatsoberhaupt selber das heißt diese
dieser Haftbefehl hat wirklich eine
außergewöhnliche Bedeutung auch wenn er
für Putin erstmal keine praktische
Konsequenz hat man muss aber ganz klar
sagen erst wenn er festgenommen ist kann
er auch angeklagt werden und kann ihm
dann auch der Prozess gemacht werden
denn vor dem Internationalen
Strafgerichtshof gibt es keinen Prozess
in Abwesenheit sollte er dort aber
jemals auf der Anklagebank sitzen dann
muss er mit bis zu 30 Jahren Gefängnis
oder lebenslang rechnen
da danke für diese juristische
Einschätzung
ja also ob man Wladimir Putin dann
tatsächlich irgendwann mal auf einer
Anklagebank sehen wird das steht also in
den Sternen doch die politische Symbolik
die in diesem internationalen Haftbefehl
steckt die ist wirklich nicht zu
unterschätzen sonst hätte der Kreml
heute wohl auch nicht so prompt und
wütend reagiert
Putins Propagandisten werden das den
russischen Volk vermutlich wieder als
Verschwörung des Westens erklären das
gilt natürlich auch für die NATO
nord-erweiterung die auch nicht so recht
zur Propaganda Linie passt dass man die
NATO erfolgreich bekämpfe und Schwäche
stattdessen rückt die NATO nun
tatsächlich näher an Russland heran mit
dem Beitritt Finnlands wird die NATO
eine über 1.300 km lange direkte Grenze
zu Russland haben die Türkei hat ihren
Widerstand gegen die aufnahmefinanz
heute aufgegeben Florian neuhahn
berichtet
willkommen wie geht's gut Ihnen auch so
kurz und sachlich die Begrüßung im Regen
von Ankara heute auch ausfällt so groß
ist die Nachricht die sich der Gast hier
abholen darf er solle kommen um zu
erfahren wie sich die Türkei zum
nato-beitrittswunsch seines Landes
verhalte das war die Einladung an den
finnischen Präsidenten und das ist die
Antwort
vielen Dank
naturkatalım Portugal wir haben
entschieden dass wir mit der
Ratifizierung des Beitritts Finnlands
beginnen wollen und ich hoffe dass diese
Entscheidung für unser Bündnis und für
unsere Länder von Nutzen sein wird
ja der Gast bedankt sich anschließend
artig und lässt nach wenigen Sätzen ein
aber folgen
ich habe das Gefühl dass die finnische
NATO-Mitgliedschaft nicht vollständig
ist ohne Schweden wir haben so viele
gemeinsame Interessen
kurz nachdem Putin die ersten Angriffe
auf die Ukraine startet beginnt im
Norden Europas ein historisches Umdenken
zwei Länder wollen gemeinsam der
nato-beitreten es wird zunächst die mit
Abstand schnellste Erweiterung der NATO
und dann doch eine Hängepartie zumindest
für Schweden das Land hat nach Ansicht
der NATO längst alle türkischen
Forderungen erfüllt etwa ein härteres
Vorgehen gegen die verbotene kurdische
PKK doch spätestens als im Januar ein
Rechtsextremist in der schwedischen
Hauptstadt den Koran verbrennt sieht man
in der Türkei rot und Erdogan da schon
im Wahlkampf erkennt einen populäres
Thema
es gebe eine rote Linie so Erdogan heute
solange man negative Schritte gegen die
Türkei beobachtete
[Musik]
schweben muss also zusehen wie der
Nachbar womöglich zuerst in die NATO
Eintritt und erfahren dass diese NATO
vielleicht nicht die Allianz der
Demokratie ist als diese sich nicht nur
in Werbevideos verkauft
es ist als ob du zu deiner Hochzeit
kommst und entdeckst dass die Braut doch
nicht so schön ist erdogan ist eine
Herausforderung für das Selbstbild der
NATO früher oder später wird man sich
entscheiden müssen zwischen westlichen
Werten und dem wofür Erdogan steht
ob es denn einen Plan B für sein Land
gebe wird der schwedische Außenminister
am Abend gefragt
wir glauben dass wir eine starke und
deutliche Unterstützung von allen
anderen nato-allierten haben und es ist
wichtig zu sehen dass nur zwei von 30
Mitgliedstaaten den Beitritt von
Schweden und Finnland noch nicht
ratifiziert haben
zwei richtig auch Ungarns Parlament hat
den Beitritt noch nicht zugestimmt auch
nicht dem finnischen übrigens und so ist
das heute nur eine Etappe im Poker um
die norderweiterung der NATO
und mit der Unterstützung der NATO für
die Ukraine geht es jetzt in den
Nachrichten noch weiter eins nach Polen
hat die Slowakei als zweites nateland
angekündigt Kampflugzeuge an die Ukraine
liefern zu wollen und zwar ebenfalls
Jets vom in der Sowjetunion entwickelten
Typen mit 29
Ministerpräsident Heger sagte es gehe um
13 Flugzeuge die von der slowakischen
Luftwaffe nicht mehr benutzt würden als
Ausgleich bekommt die Slowakei von der
EU 200 Millionen Euro sowie Waffen von
den USA auch im Wert von mehreren
hundert Millionen
Chinas Staatschef hier reist Anfang
kommender Woche für mehrere Tage nach
Moskau zu Gesprächen mit dem russischen
Präsidenten Putin eines der zentralen
Themen sei die Vertiefung der
Partnerschaft der beiden Länder hieß es
von russischer Seite die US-Regierung
forderte hier auf im Zuge seines
moskau-besuchs auch mit dem ukrainischen
Präsidenten selenski zu sprechen um sich
über die ukrainische Sicht zu
informieren
Bundeskanzler Scholz ist mit sechs
Ministerinnen und Ministern zur
Regierungskonsultationen nach Japan
aufgebrochen bei den Gesprächen soll es
vor allem um eine engere wirtschaftliche
Zusammenarbeit gehen wie Japan will sich
auch die Bundesregierung unabhängige von
Importen aus China machen außerdem
sollen Tokio über gemeinsame
militärische Projekte beraten werden
mit einem Wochenende der Demokratie
erinnert Berlin an dem März Revolution
von 1848 bei einer Gedenkveranstaltung
heute Abend den Schloss Bellevue rief
Bundespräsident Steinmeier zur
Verteidigung einer wehrhaften Demokratie
in Deutschland auf steinmeier sagte
schwarz rot und gold das sind die
historischen Farben unserer Demokratie
lassen wir nicht zu dass diese Farben
heute von Verächtern der Demokratie
missbraucht werden
in der Stadt Bremen droht der innerlich
zerstrittenen AFD ein Ausschluss von der
Bürgerschaftswahl in rund zwei Monaten
die dortige Wahlleitung ließ vorläufig
keine afd-liste zu aus der Partei sein
zwei konkurrierende Wahlvorschläge
eingegangen eine Partei dürfe aber nur
eine Kandidatenliste einreichen beide
Partei Lager kündigten an Beschwerde
beim Landeswahlausschuss einzulegen
dieser soll am kommenden Donnerstag
beraten
die Kultusminister der Länder wollen
verstärkt gegen den Lehrermangel
Vorgehen dazu sollten auch neue Wege
eröffnet werden hieß es nach Beratungen
in Berlin unter anderem sollen
Lehrkräfte gewonnen werden indem der
Wechsel von einem fachwissenschaftlichen
oder künstlerischen Studiengang in die
Lehramtsstudiengänge erleichtert wird zu
den weiteren Beschlüssen der
Kultusminister gehört eine Angleichung
beim Abitur um es vergleichbarer zu
machen
massiven Proteste in Frankreich gegen
macrons Rentenreform erinnern ja ein
bisschen daran wie in Deutschland
seinerzeit die Schröder-Regierung die
agenda-reform durchsetzte dem damaligen
Bundeskanzler ist das bekanntlich am
Ende nicht gut bekommen nun sind die
Verhältnisse in Frankreich und
Frankreichs Regierungssystem ein anderes
deshalb konnte der französische
Präsident diese Reform auch am Parlament
vorbei beschließen aufhalten könnten
ihnen und seine Regierung nur ein
erfolgreiches Misstrauensvotum
entsprechende Anträge wurden heute
eingereicht aus Paris berichtet Thomas
Walter
am Abend versammeln sich in Paris
tausende zum Protest
so wie am Nachmittag in Rennen
Schüler demonstrieren
Arbeiter blockieren eine
Müllverbrennungsanlage und
Vertriebszentren wir sind noch
entschlossener wir machen weiter mit der
Blockade bis wir gewinnen
in weiten Teilen Frankreichs Flammen
heute die Proteste auf wütender als
zuvor mit Aktionen die auch das
französische Streikrecht nicht deckt wie
die Blockade von Autobahnen
dies ist eine Reaktion auf die
Entscheidung der Regierung der 49.3
anzuwenden wenn die Regierung blockiert
blockieren wir auch
49.3 auf macrons Stirn geschrieben die
Zahl ist Kurzform für den neuen Protest
49.3 ist der verfassungsparagraph mit
dem die Regierung gestern die
Rentenreform durchs Parlament peitschte
erlaubt Gesetze ohne Abstimmung durch
Abgeordnete die Regierung hatte zuvor
vergeblich versucht eine Mehrheit
zustande zu bringen man sah ihren
Mitgliedern förmlich an dass sie selbst
mit dem Vorgehen nicht glücklich war
wir können nicht die Zukunft der Renten
riskieren diese Reform ist notwendig
die Opposition bestreitet das Franzosen
länger arbeiten müssen um die Rente zu
finanzieren sie ist empört dass die
Regierung sich an der Abstimmung
entzieht und nutzt im Gegenzug eine
Möglichkeit die der 49.3 auch eröffnet
Misstrauens voten gegen die Regierung es
geht darum unsere missachtete
parlamentarische Demokratie zu bewahren
und die soziale Demokratie sie
verhindern dass das französische Volk
seinen Willen durch seine Repräsentanten
ausdrückt sie haben keine Mehrheit für
ihre Reform gefunden weil sie schlecht
waren
bekommt die Opposition eine Mehrheit für
ein Misstrauensvotum muss die Regierung
abtreten bekommt die Opposition keine
Mehrheit ist die Rentenreform durch
Zünglein an der Waage sind die Republika
die haben in der Vergangenheit gegen
misstrauensanträge gestimmt sicher ist
dass diesmal nicht macron der sich heute
nicht äußerte versprach eins das Land zu
einem nun polarisiert er mehr als zuvor
Immanuel hat für die weitere Amtszeit
wohl keine Mehrheit mehr der Präsident
der französischen Republik ist dem Recht
nach nicht wirklich mächtig er ist nur
mächtig wenn er eine Mehrheit hinter
sich hat und diese Mehrheit scheint es
heute nicht zu geben
Misstrauen im Parlament Kampf auf der
Straße Frankreich fürchtet eine
Radikalisierung der Aktionen schon
gestern kam es zu harten
Auseinandersetzungen möglich das immer
nur macron in der kommenden Woche seine
wichtigste Reform durchbringt aber teuer
für sie bezahlt
und jetzt noch mal Heinz mit dem Blick
auf die Finanzmärkte da ist ja einiges
los im Moment ja auch zum Ende dieser
Börsenwoche schauen wir wieder auf den
Bankensektor die Situation beschäftigt
auch die Europäische Zentralbank
valeriehalle wie sind die aktuellen
Einschätzungen und es bleibt turbulent
die EZB wenigstens versucht zu
beschwichtigen der Bankensektor sei
widerstandsfähig und Bundeskanzler
Scholz sagt er sehe keine Gefahr für
eine neue Krise auch US-Präsident beiden
ist bemüht die Nerven zu beruhigen an
den Finanzmärkten aber verhallen diese
Beruhigungsversuche die Börse hoch
nervös der DAX beendet den Tag Knie tief
im Minus denn mit der Kredit Swiss Gerät
eine systemrelevante Banken Schieflage
die das Zeug dazu hat potenziell eine
globale Finanzkrise auszulösen allein
diese Woche haben Anleger wieder
hunderte Millionen Euro aus Fonds der
Bank abgezogen das Problem kommt es zum
sogenannten Bank Run müssen Banken
schnell Geld L machen um ihre Kunden
auszuzahlen verkaufen Papiere teils mit
großen Verlusten und manche überleben
das nicht die Wochenbilanz der Aktie
jedenfalls düster -24 Prozent unter
Druck auch die deutschen Geldhäuser die
Commerzbank und die Deutsche Bank beide
kräftig im Minus mit mehreren
Rettungspaketen versuchen Aufseher und
Großbanken die Lage zu stabilisieren in
Europa und den USA das sind auch
vertrauensmaßnahmen denn Vertrauen ist
die kostbarste Währung von Banken ohne
können sie nicht überleben wie die
Geschichte ausgeht keiner weiß es nur
eines die Gefahr ist noch nicht gebannt
vielen Dank
nach einem Aufruf der Gewerkschaft Verdi
haben Warnstreiks erneut zu massiven
Flug Ausfällen und Verspätungen geführt
an den Flughäfen Köln Bonn Düsseldorf
und Stuttgart wurden insgesamt rund 580
Flüge gestrichen mehr als 76.000
Passagiere waren betroffen Hintergrund
sind Verhandlungen zur Bezahlung in der
luftsicherheitsbranche und der
Tarifstreit im öffentlichen Dienst
im europäischen Fußball sind heute die
Viertelfinalbegegnungen ausgelost worden
in der Europa League trifft Bayer
Leverkusen auf Union Saints aus Belgien
und in der Champions League ergab die
Auslosung in Lyon für den FC Bayern als
Gegner Manchester City das zuletzt 7:0
gegen Leipzig gewonnen hat das Hinspiel
ist am 11 April in Manchester das
Rückspiel in München in der Woche darauf
die Forschungsgruppe Wahlen hat die
Bundesbürger wieder zu aktuellen
politischen Themen befragt und natürlich
auch die Sonntagsfrage gestellt alle
Ergebnisse im Politbarometer präsentiert
Ihnen jetzt Antje Pieper
[Musik]
herzlich willkommen zum Politbarometer
es besteht dringender Handlungsbedarf im
deutschen Bildungssystem da sind sich
alle einig zehntausende fehlende Lehrer
Grundschüler die nicht richtig lesen und
rechnen können immer mehr Schulabbrecher
die Befragten im Politbarometer Stellen
der Politik ein schlechtes Zeugnis aus
91% sagen in Deutschland wird zu wenig
für Bildung und Schule getan
auf dem Bildungsgipfel Anfang der Woche
hat die Bundesministerin für mehr
Zusammenarbeit geworben prompt das erste
Land auf Eigenständigkeit die Befragten
im Politbarometer haben dazu eine klare
Haltung
22% finden dass die Schul- und
Bildungspolitik Ländersache bleiben soll
drei Viertel der Befragten aber wollen
dass der Bund deutlich mehr mitzureden
hat
mehr Kompetenzen für den Bund könnte
auch bedeuten mehr Ausgaben für marode
Schulgebäude zum Beispiel
übergehen in der Koalition die
Vorstellungen auseinander was sich der
Staat leisten kann und soll die Ampel
streitet ums Geld und darüber wofür es
in den nächsten Jahren ausgegeben werden
soll SPD Grüne und FDP setzen dabei
unterschiedliche Schwerpunkte wegen
ukrainekrieg Inflation und Energiekrise
fehlt für die vielen Pläne das Geld doch
woher nehmen durch Einsparungen in
anderen Bereichen sagen 57 Prozent der
Befragten nur 18 Prozent wollen dafür
Steuererhöhungen fast ebenso viele sind
für zusätzliche Schulden
in der Ampel geht es zunehmend gereizt
zu darin konnte auch die Klausur in
Meseberg wenig ändern
63% schätzen das Koalitionsklima
mittlerweile als eher schlecht ein
die Androhung von Verkehrsminister
Wissing das auf EU-Ebene geplante aus
für verbrennermotoren nachzuverhandeln
hat den grünen Koalitionspartner
überrascht und verstimmt der Minister
hat in dieser Frage die Mehrheit im
Politbarometer auf seiner Seite 34
Prozent sind dafür ab 2035 keine Autos
mit Verbrennermotor mehr zuzulassen eine
Mehrheit von 61% ist dagegen
Mehrheiten gegen das Verbot finden sich
bei den Anhängern aller Parteien nur die
der Grünen sind überwiegend dafür
die Pläne des Verkehrsministers haben
auch die klimaaktivisten der letzten
Generation auf dem Plan gerufen mit
einer Farbattacke auf das Ministerium
die Gruppe setzt auf Provokation das
illegale
klimaschutz-ticket oder Tempolimit dafür
stoppt die Gruppe ihre Blockade mehr als
jeder zweite findet solche
Vereinbarungen richtig 41% lehnen sie ab
vor allem die Jüngeren befürworten sie
bei den unter 35-Jährigen sind es zwei
Drittel mit zunehmenden Alter aber singt
die Zustimmung
bei unserer Projektion gibt es in dieser
Woche kaum Bewegung wenn am Sonntag
Bundestagswahl wäre käme die SPD auf 21
Prozent cdu/csu 29% beide unverändert
grüne 19% +1 FDP unverändert 5% AFD 14 -
1 linke 5 und verändert
damit würde es für schwarz-rot oder
knapp für Schwarz-Grün reichen nicht
aber für die regierende Ampel oder ein
Bündnis von SPD GRÜNEN und Linke
die Ampel hätte aktuell also keine
parlamentarische Mehrheit die
ampelvertreter aber können sich bei der
persönlichen Bewertung durchweg
verbessern unsere Liste der wichtigsten
Politiker und Politikerinnen die von den
Befragten bestimmt wird auf das Skala
von +5 bis -5 bewertet nach Sympathie
und Leistung
Alice Weidel bleibt Schlusslicht -2,8
davor Sahra Wagenknecht -1,5 beide
schlechter Friedrich Merz -0,4 klare
Verluste Markus Söder minus 0,2
verschlechtert Platz 6 für Christian
Lindner minus 0,1 besser Karl Lauterbach
0,2 mit klarem + Platz 4 Annalena
baerbock 0,6 etwas besser der dritte
Platz für Robert Habeck 0,7 auch eher
besser auf dem zweiten Platz Olaf Scholz
1,0 stark verbessert ganz vorne weiter
Boris Pistorius mit 1,9 auch mit zu
wechseln
fast jeden Tag ein neuer Streik im
öffentlichen Dienst so sieht es derzeit
im Land aus die Gewerkschaft Verdi und
der Beamtenbund legen das öffentliche
Leben weitgehend lahm und wollen damit
ihre Forderungen in der laufenden
Tarifrunde untermauern
mehr als Dreiviertel der Befragten haben
Verständnis für die Warnstreiks 20%
lehnen sie ab
auch wenn die Folgen der Streiks
tausende zu spüren bekommen ist das
Verständnis und die Unterstützung für
die Belange der Beschäftigten also groß
das war unser Bericht über die Stimmung
im Land die Grafiken und alle
Informationen zu unseren Umfragen bitten
Sie wie immer in zdf-text auf Seite 165
in der ZDF heute App und auf ZDF
heute.de wie die repräsentativen
Umfragen der Forschungsgruppe waren
Zustandekommen Informationen zur
Methodik und zu den Qualitätsstandards
finden Sie unter Politbarometer zdf.de
vielen Dank für Ihr Interesse das
nächste Politbarometer gibt es am 31
März nach dem Wetter geht es hier gleich
weiter mit der heute-
[Musik]
einen wunderschönen guten Abend zum
Wetter ja in diesem März da war es schon
ordentlich nass in den Grünen und in den
blauen Flächen hier da hat der März
schon zwischen 80 und über 100% seines
Regen solls erfüllt und da kann ja noch
etwas dazu kommen was die Hälfte des
Monats ist ja noch übrig und darauf
hoffen dann vor allem die Regionen an
der Küste und auch in Ober- und in
Niederbayern da fielen bisher nämlich
nur 20% von dem was wir im ganzen Monat
erwarten würden und heute Nacht und
morgen mit diesem Wolkenband hier über
Deutschland kommt da auch noch etwas
Regen dazu viel ist das aber nicht in
den nächsten Tagen jetzt zum Wochenende
statt kommt da vor allem erstmal diese
milde Luft die sorgt dann dafür dass
heute Nacht die Werte in
Nordrhein-Westfalen nicht unter zehn
Grad singen in Niederbayern gibt's noch
mal leichten Frost die nächsten Tage
sind dann aber frostfrei vom Schwarzwald
bis zum Erzgebirge ist es heute Nacht
klar vereinzelt gibt es Niebel im
Nordosten das sind dann aber diese
Wolken und vom Saarland bis zur Ostsee
gibt's immer wieder schauerartig
verstärkt der Regen und das schreibt
dann auch die Zugbahn für die shower
morgen das sind keine großen Regenmengen
da gibt es auch zwischendurch immer
Sonne aber wenn sich mal ein Gewitter
entwickelt ganz ordentlich prasseln und
der Wind etwas auffrischen in Bayern und
in Baden-Württemberg scheint Morgen viel
die Sonne und dazu ist es ein sehr
milder Tag verbreitet diese
vorfrühlingshafte 15 bis 20 Grad nur an
der Küste sind es etwas weniger und in
den nächsten Tagen bleiben wir erstmal
in diesem zweistelligen Bereich auch
wenn es am Montag etwas nach unten geht
am Sonntag wird es auch wechselhaft also
überall auch im Süden sind dann Schauer
und vereinzelte Gewitter möglich ab
Montag zum Frühlingsbeginn am 20 März
sieht das ganze dann aber auswärts ab
und es wird etwas trockener das war es
von uns tschüss